[Music]
all right um let's do this i've got a
few things to talk about but first sean
let's talk to ben ben had a big night
why are we even talking
we are now the sideshow we're the
openers actually for the main event
ben
ben made event wilson what's up dude how
are you feeling well let's let's let's
not even tell them why
so here here's the here's the setup sean
and i were chilling last night and we
get a text from ben
and he says hey look who just followed
me and it was mr beast and i think it's
so for context everyone ben is our
producer here ben has a podcast called
how to take over the world it's uh it's
fairly popular but growing quickly so
uh your twitter only has like a thousand
or two thousand followers right
four thousand four still yeah four
thousand so we get this message and you
said hey look who uh look who just
started following me and it was mr beast
and sean and i made fun of you saying
like uh you know that's nothing no big
deal then you sent a text message to us
saying
uh been on the phone with them for the
past hour and a half and we were like
wait what and we don't really know we
don't know anything else so
yeah of course there's gonna be some
stuff here that you can't talk about
but what happened
yeah so uh
i got back from utah with my in-laws on
saturday so i was like feeling a little
jet lagged i was about to go to bed
early getting into bed with my wife
and uh i looked down on my phone and
i've got a notification says mr beast
followed you and my first thought is
like oh yeah mr beast followed me like
mr underscore beast hey give me my
social security number and i'll venmo
you five thousand dollars so i literally
i saw it and i just put down my phone
and
uh like keep just like chatting with my
wife or whatever and then i pick it up
five minutes later and i look at it and
i go
i actually don't see an underscore i
don't i don't see anything wrong with
this and i click on it and it's verified
and it's mr beast and he just followed
me and i was like oh that's weird like
you said i only have 4 000 followers
like it's not
it's not a normal thing for like i just
you know pick up mr beast and then i get
a dm like two minutes later and uh
he's like hey um
i listened to your podcast i think it's
cool i would love to chat sometime i
don't want anything from you i just like
want to learn and i was like so i
respond i say cool yeah let's uh talk
anytime i'm free like anytime you want
to talk next week you sound like you're
playing it cool but inside what's going
on
yeah so inside i was like
actually even outside i was like my wife
is katie like katie katie katie
once it starts happening
and uh she was like what and i was like
mr beast's following me she's like
what's a mr beast and i was like no i
gotta call someone else that's what i
texted you guys because like she doesn't
get it i need to talk to someone who
gets it katie leave the room
like go get me a 12 year old stat who
could have a discussion about this
katie get your nephew on the line
yeah
uh she's getting mad at me if i talk
about her though once i explained who he
was she was very very excited she was
very very excited um so uh i uh i
messaged him yeah and i'm like trying to
play cool like uh oh yeah cool i could i
could make time no problem um
and uh should i run or crawl to you
and then he hits me with the sean and
he's like uh how about right now
and i'm like
sitting there
like in my boxers in my bed and i'm like
yep i am 100 ready to talk right now uh
calm call me and uh so
he
called me
and
apparently he does this
uh at night he goes for walks and he
just calls people who he thinks are
interesting and he tries to like
download their brains and learn anything
that he can
uh so
uh we talked for like almost two and a
half hours uh at the end and he's a
very cool dude and i learned a lot of
cool stuff
well what like well and yeah
i mean
what did you guys talk about
uh we talked about a lot like it was you
know it was just like a personal
conversation so i'm not gonna share
everything that we talked about but um
oh i mean what for me the the
coolest thing he did was
yeah i've i've known for a long time
that i need to take my podcast to
youtube and i got to ask him like okay
so how should i do this and he basically
walked me through
how he would do it um and how would he
do it general game plan uh basically i
was saying you know should i do segments
should i do
uh clips
should i
um animate it should i do me on the
screen and what he said is do the full
episodes
uh you probably want to edit the scripts
a little bit so that it's not quite so
casual uh because podcast like you
listen to as you're washing the dishes
like it doesn't matter that it's not
gripping every second
of the of the audio but for youtube like
it does need to be gripping every second
like really needs to pull people second
by second so he said you need to edit
your script a little bit for video do
animations do it highly produced and do
the full episodes like 45 minutes to an
hour long that was the basic strategy
and then he gave me some comps some
channels that i should make it similar
to
and
some homework up on what did he want to
ask you right because he called you so
um
you know was he looking for something
was he just saying hey tell me about you
know i'm walking around i want to hear
i've listened to your podcast and i
decided i'd like you to say it out loud
to me live go like what was he what was
he interested in
he was laying in bed and he said ben
tell me about my heroes yeah and uh
uh no he yeah he
the funny thing was
he didn't really know so we were just
like talking about random stuff and he's
like i just want to learn from you so i
don't know
what's up man like that's kind of how we
went into it and i was like i don't know
what's up with you um
and uh so then we just kind of started
chatting about random topics i asked him
a lot of stuff i he told me a lot of
cool stuff that is not public
information
and
and then
at the end he was asking me sort of
about
um like guru is honestly very similar i
told you about that finance guy yeah
yeah and like wants me to be his guru
the background is very similar the
background of that is like this person
worth hundreds of millions of dollars
hollered at ben and said just tell me
what mistakes i'm going to make before i
make them based off of like historical
people so ben's podcast is he basically
reads three books on titans of industry
and he breaks them down into like a two
or three hour podcast so so by in theory
ben's an expert a three book expert on a
lot of different people and and if
you're gonna listen to one go listen to
edison i think it's amazing sam what's
your favorite one edison to me is by far
my favorite uh what's the uh richest uh
roth child i like the rothschild one but
i do think the edison one is the is the
most impactful because it like we all
know the outcome of edison the disney
one people liked um i didn't like that
as much because disney like is not as
interesting to me but uh that one's
probably the most popular
so interestingly i for disney i almost
did a follow-up at the end of it because
i listened to mr b's interview on joe
rogan and the stuff mr beast was saying
i was like oh this person is so similar
to walt disney that it's almost kind of
spooky and maybe i should make uh a
podcast just pointing out like a a quick
10 minute one pointing out the
similarities between walt disney and mr
beast and when he got on the phone he
was like i loved the walt disney one
that really resonated with me and i was
like oh that doesn't matter dude this is
why like you
you're you're you're pretty under
monetized but i think it's gonna catch
up soon because i think what's gonna
happen and we said this six months ago
you make these comments like oh you
remind me of walt disney and so if i'm
the person who like if i'm mr beast and
you said it to me i go really what um
what mistake like what am i doing wrong
um or like uh i'm thinking about doing x
y and z did walt do this and like did it
work and did it not work like you're
this weird fortune teller type of person
and that
did he say something like that to you
yeah a little bit um a little bit he got
into the like well what mistakes should
i look out for like what do you think
that um
like what do you think i need to be wary
of there's and like there's a charlie
munger quote that's like um
tell me where i'm gonna die so i know i
never go there right like i'll just make
sure never to go there
it's kind of that but i'm sure there's
also the upside right like it's not just
what mistakes but like how did they make
their greatness happen i think that's
actually more of what people care about
how do they make their greatness happen
and then kind of draw parallels to my
own life of like yeah
i am just like edison and the
rothschilds and disney after all you
know uh it's so similar right
i think you know like for mr beast i
think the parallels are super easy with
walt disney the thing the only time that
walt disney slowed down in his career
was for like a decade and it was because
walt loved to be working on a new thing
but a certain point everyone convinced
him like oh actually you have this
enormous multi-million dollar animation
studio now you just need to be working
on pumping out more full-length
animations
and
like when he did that the whole thing
kind of went downhill and then he goes
crazy and he starts obsessing over
little toy trains and like
really going off the rails but those
those model trains then get bigger and
bigger and becomes disneyland and that
is when he comes out of his funk and
starts innovating again and so for mr
beast it's just like the don't let
anyone convince you that you need to be
working on the reasonable thing like you
need to follow
your unreasonable passions because some
somehow great things are going to come
out so that's kind of the parallel for
context walt disney
i can't imagine he was more successful
than mr beast was at mr b stage but
how big was his business when it when
you say things were going were being
becoming unsuccessful and he started
focusing and what does focusing mean
like was he was he the ceo of this
company
um walt was essentially the ceo of walt
disney studios yeah uh
and this is basically in the 40s and
early 50s
um
and it was
not huge huge but it was like
hundreds to maybe just over a thousand
employees is how big wow well disney
studios was
damn dude well ben i think this was cool
as hell i'm so happy for you that that
happened these are cool moments along
the way and sit kind of like signals
that like you're on the right track uh
you know sam
discovered you i don't know when
uh he came on a year ago
it was a year ago
and you did this awesome there's
somebody put a twitter clip up you did
some interview and you were like
you're like i'm listening to my first
million and i hear sam
say
uh man
i found this podcast i love it's called
how to take over the world
and i thought to myself huh there's
another podcast called how to take over
the world how cool is that and then
you're like oh [__] he's talking about
me ben wilson he just said my name and
then you know
and then we basically then i went down
the rabbit hole after sam said it i was
like that sounds like really interesting
i don't like to read biographies but i
think i'd like to listen to two hours
and like that's just you know like one
commute and i could like know the story
of edison i listened to the edison one i
got hooked i called you basically right
after that i think i dm'd you and called
you and i was like hey let's partner
like i think your thing is going to blow
up
come work for us on our podcast and then
we will help cross promote your
broadcast and like let's take this to
the next level and these are the little
happenings that happen along the way and
now you know mr beast following you know
sam and my lead of recognizing your
talents for what they are
and um and so you know honestly like i
think you have a great thing going i'm
really happy for you that you know this
happened i think it's such a cool thing
that happened i think what would be cool
and i think this might happen ben here's
what i'm going to predict that's going
to happen in the next month you're going
to record an episode with jimmy mr beast
you're going to record an episode with
mr beast and i think you if you you
should ask him you should text him be
like hey next time you want to do a
sunday talk can i just record it and
we're going to talk about history and
i'm going to make it an episode do care
and every it's going to be really cool
because it's going to be like when elon
musk went on um or wouldn't like i
forget it was like
elon musk went on a couple like like uh
he went on wait but why history hardcore
history and it's like dude well hardcore
history is like bigger than you ben but
the even to the mainstream person they
were like why is elon musk appearing on
this nerdy
niche thing and it blows it up and
that's what's gonna happen it's gonna be
all the young people are gonna be like
why is mr beast on this history thing
what is going on who is this and i think
that's what's going to happen and your
life is going to change i predict that's
that's this is this is how that story is
going to play out
you should definitely reach out with
some idea you just need to what's what
is the idea of how he could join you on
the thing
and like just get that one thing right
and it'll be like an inflection point
for for you and what you do well it
should be it should be why mr beast is
the new walt disney and you're going to
be like hey i'm going to tell you i'm
going to
jimmy uh his name's jimmy right i'm
going to tell you why how you are just
like walt disney but i'm going to do it
in front of everyone and you can ask me
questions and i'll explain to you why uh
that's that's why i think you are just
like him i think that'll be really cool
i think what i would want to do is if he
would let me like go down
to north carolina and like interview his
parents interview his friends and like
actually kind of make like a
semi-documentary audio documentary out
of it the making of mr beast
that would be sick and also you could it
could be like this is the part one
of may of hopefully many parts to come
and i'm gonna do this you know i can i
can kind of document your whole whole
thing how this turns out but you're only
20 what is he 25 26 years old something
like that it's like
you know this is this is part one
you know what's funny part one i was
talking to him and uh
i was talking about like just look at
the smile on your face bro this is like
you know wow i have never seen this sort
of deep happiness inside you this is
amazing
so i i was talking about like yeah these
guys call me up and think i'm their guru
and so like i'm i might do like a
consulting business off of it um like
coaching type of thing because peop
there seems to be a market for that and
he was like oh yeah
i could see that that seems like
something i would have gone for when i
was younger and i was like when you were
younger you're 24 years old like how
much time is there of when you were
younger he's like i used to feel just
like that yesterday
he's like yeah when i was younger you're
like i have a child
seven years older than you and i have a
child all right i'll be uh
that's funny he just big dogged you in a
very nice way
yeah he did did you a favor he he kind
of like [__] on you in the most gentle
way possible in a way that's helpful to
you
yes exactly well congratulations that's
cool all right i'm excited to see what's
going to happen
um
all right sean i have what else we got
i've got a few interesting things for
you let me tell you the first
interesting thing that i'm doing in my
life and kind of an interesting business
so
i'm on this app called intro are you
using intro
i don't use it no but uh
let's explain what it is it's basically
like you call an expert for an hour and
you pay for the time and you could do
like a 15 or 30 minute call with them
yeah that's all it is it's that and
that's not the point of the story but
that's like that's all it is it's just
you pay money to talk to people it's
consulting and my buddy started it so he
asked me to do it so i said yeah fine
i'll sign up whatever so when you and i
were in miami this man and woman this
husband and wife came up to me and like
started talking to me about hypnotherapy
because they knew that i was uh afraid
to fly i i've got like i have a pretty
hardcore claustrophobic thing i don't
take subways i don't fly and i also have
an addictive personality and i love
sugar and so they like knew that and
they were trying to pitch me and they on
like using their services and they kept
emailing me and i just i ignore everyone
i don't reply to email really and
eventually they book a intro call with
me and i charge like i put it at like
two grand an hour
and they're like hey you never answer
our emails and and to be honest when i
met them i did you know like you we do
the nice thing when meet people oh yeah
you know this sounds great like you know
maybe i'll do it sometime like you're
just trying to be polite and i just find
a time yeah let's find a time and let's
run away from potentially talking to
each other
yeah and they booked a call with me and
they go you said you're gonna do it we
can't get you down so we're just gonna
pay you money right now and we're going
to sit down and do a hypno
a hip uh what's it called hip what do
you call it hypnosis i guess a hypnosis
session and i'm like okay i don't know
what that what that's about but i i do
it
and it kind of has changed my like the
game for me and so what
yes and i'll explain to you what but uh
i keep getting the words screwed up
hypnotherapy what is it called hypnosis
uh
they uh this woman so she has an app her
name is grace i think getgrace.com is
like her app and then i don't know i
think like grace.tv if you go to
getgrace.com i'm sure you'll see all
about her her name is grace and she
told me she's like look here's the deal
a handful of executives pay me a million
dollars a year to do to be their
personal hypnotist
i'm not gonna pay you that or i'm not
gonna charge you that but if you like it
you have to tell people about it i said
whatever fine but i'm not paying you a
million dollars she's like that's fine
but you just get let me give you five
sessions and if it changes you let me
know if you want to talk about it and so
i do this do this thing
it's totally worked
so basically what it is is you know how
you do uh breath work and meditation you
just like kind of like sit down and get
quiet and like you hear like a voice in
your head like it's maybe your
headphones it's andy from headspace and
he says like all right imagine like the
sun is pouring on your
mind or on your brain and it's leaking
down to your body and causing you to
like relax and you're filling with like
relaxation whatever you basically do
that but then she talks to you while
you're in that state you know that
meditative state and she says things
like you know imagine yourself on a
beach in your safe space and imagine
like there's four-year-old you and
you're explaining to him how you're
trying to overcome like you know the
sugar addiction or whatever the thing
you're trying to overcome and so uh and
tell me what you say to that person so
you're basically just like talk you're
getting spoken to and you're sometimes
speaking back in a meditative state not
like that interesting when i did it i
was like oh i thought i was gonna be in
a trance but for some reason this has
been wildly effective i think it could
be placebo i think it could not be but i
don't care i haven't had sugar in like
three weeks since i started this and i
like
am i kind of an addict with that stuff
and it's like to the point where i get
sick if i think about it it's been crazy
fascinating and she gets these she gets
all these people to pay her a million
dollars a year is that is that real
though who's who's paying her does she
does she name names who's paying her a
million dollars a year that sounds a
little far-fetched
it does sound a bit far-fet fetched on
her website is the founder of clearco uh
clearco what are they called their
they're called like clear banker or
something yeah they were uh that guy is
uh one of her testimonials and then she
told me other people who uh i actually
don't know if i'm allowed to say who
those other people are oh yeah so that's
great
her website yeah well her website is
great grace gracesmithtv.com
and on there you could see testimonials
from people so could it she be like kind
of pulling my leg yeah i mean i didn't
like look at her financials yes 100
but
i don't know who i mean would someone
lie about that like it looks way
different for some reason i imagine her
to be like 70 but she's not she's very
young so grace smith is the world's
leading hypnotherapist it is a seven
figure investment to work with grace
uh wow that's amazing you can work with
her team for less or download the grace
app for free okay grace app for free
that sounds promising
all right so the uh
the founder of clearbank
wow she's been on uh you know whatever
something's tv show jimmy kimmel but
it's not it's called the noit contenilo
gentilly
it's the brazilian version it's the
brazilian version of jimmy kimmel yeah
so okay so yours was around sugar or was
around for your sugar and we're gonna
we're gonna address the the flying thing
later but i was gonna try and do sugar
and uh it's actually been effective
i'm i'm shocked to say it's been
effective
that's kind of crazy um i like it and it
makes me want to do it which i think is
probably you know pretty common she told
me to tell you that you can do it for
free too if you want oh okay great how
do i get over my what do i even have i
don't have as much yeah the problem is
is that you're like emotionally healthy
so i like i don't know if you have
issues um get over this happiness thing
i got every day
yeah so i don't know if like it's gonna
impact you i don't know like if you have
any diet yeah it could be food it could
be food related like you know do i
really want that cheese pizza maybe i'll
just never eat a cheese pizza again
after i talk to grace that could be kind
of nice it's it's just kind of
interesting but it could be a thing
where it's like man i gotta meet with
this woman every week and like if i tell
her that i ate sugar i'm to feel like an
idiot so i mean that could be it i i
don't know what it is but
it's kind of interesting i started using
that my body tutor after you had
mentioned it on the podcast so did you
really they definitely had a bump i
signed up i paid for it so i was like
all right let's try this out
it's legit right now for multiple weeks
it's super legit i mean it's like
there's no like hocus pocus it's like
just straight up here's a kind of like a
coach who's a nutritionist who's like
gonna really help you so i have this
woman haley helping me i don't know if
she's the most same one you have i have
heather
okay so um i don't know about heather
but haley's amazing and so
uh and a lot of it's just like the basic
psychology of accountability right like
i tell her i'm gonna do something and i
take a photo of every meal and i have to
think to myself
am i gonna either a be a big fat liar
and just not take a picture of this like
you know bag of cheez-its that i'm about
to eat or
am i gonna take a picture of it and be
like yeah i know i told you i was going
to eat good and then i just ate bad even
though clearly i could have just not
you know not eaten bad and so it's
helped so much to clear up like you know
just like i don't know let's call it 30
or 40
of just random [__] mistakes that i
would have been making plus then there's
the strategy like okay
she gave me this i'll share an exam
specific example so like she told me
this thing she goes all right
uh
i i snapped a picture of a meal i ate
she goes like whoa big meal and i'm like
yeah yeah you know whatever she's got
you know her job is to kind of judge my
meals right okay fair
and she's like do me a favor before you
eat i want you to just on a scale of one
to five just take take note just like at
the beginning here i'm not gonna change
anything in your diet but just observe
how hungry were you when you started the
meal like if one is absolutely starving
and five is absolutely stuffed like were
you starving when you when you decided
to eat or were you
like a two or three on the hunger scale
and then when you were done were you
like um so stuffed i need a nap or are
you like
you know okay i'm full i'm done and
she's like don't change anything just
like give yourself a number before and
after after every meal so i started
doing it and she's like i was like so
what do i want like you know start at a
two and end at a four she's like no you
kind of want to start at a three and end
at a three like you know you basically
want to be like okay it's been about
three hours i think i'll like i'll eat
now i think i could eat i don't have to
eat but i could i could definitely eat
right now because you're creating like
patterns and being consistent and when
i'm done eating it's like i don't stop
eating when i can't physically eat
anymore i stop eating because like cool
like i've had enough of my meal and i
can move on i know that there's gonna be
more food in a couple hours i don't need
to like you know stuff myself to the
brim here and so literally these like
very small like nuances so i'd notice oh
man i really do tend to eat bad when i
get to a one because then i'm just like
i'm redlining i gotta i just like my
decision making is very poor there
so i'm like normally if i like eat at a
two and i finish at a three
i'm like very proud of like those all
those meals so little things like that
or you know certain like like hey give
me i was like yo give me a grocery list
i'm going to whole foods just give me a
grocery list and i'm just going to buy
only that [__] so i only have that to
eat at home like you know let's make
this simple
and so she gave me like an exact grocery
list i went and bought all that stuff i
was like oh this is great so it's an
amazing service
yeah my my coach was like anytime you
want a snack because i would like snack
a lot she was like get a baked potato
put it a paper towel over it and rinse
the bake get it wet and just put it in
the microwave for five minutes and just
eat that and i started eating that i'm
like oh this is delicious this tastes
wonderful and it's only 150 calories so
like i was like what the [__] is a sweet
potato i didn't know what a sweet potato
was
you know what i mean
it's like
that's what you call your girlfriend
when you're in high school
it's like dave chappelle when they do
switching spouses when the black guy
goes with the white family and he goes
what the [__] is a parsnip like he
doesn't know what a parsnip is it's like
i don't know what a [__] sweet potato
is
[Laughter]
who's renee zell wisher that's what he
says
yeah
so anyway it's been a good service i
like my body tour it's good me too me
too this is not an ad we're not paid to
do it i genuinely like the product and
it's helping me
also it's like 700 a month and i don't
want to spend that anymore but i said
the only way i'm quitting is when i'm
here it's like 200 250.
i do the thing where they call you every
single day
okay so they call me they call me every
morning and i can't cheat because my
wife and fa and like family knows that
i'm doing it and they're like oh you're
going to tell heather that you just ate
that i'm like well that was the biggest
thing i had to make a decision
am i is this 100 honesty or is this 90
honesty or 60 honesty like you know
there are levels to this whole honesty
thing and so i was like all right
i decided if i'm gonna spend this money
i gotta do 100 honesty i don't know this
person i've never met this person
like she's gonna be my little confidant
of every single thing i eat in
the exact thing like
yeah i i did just put ranch on my potato
like yeah that that happened you know
like
i can't explain it i just did it and so
i'm like i gotta take the actual photo
of the actual thing every single time no
matter what and i think that also
the commitment to actually doing it
right is what actually makes you get a
good result from things
um do you want me to keep going you want
to do another one let me do another one
yeah let's go
all right have you heard of aviator
nation
no
all right so this is this week's billy
of the week so basically
um have you heard of um tom shoes
remember tom shoes like give one of
course buy one give one type of thing
you know like the hipster shoes well
anyway the guy who started it his name
was blake by the way
you go to africa are we is everybody
just running around to tell them shoes
they better be at this point yeah at
this point yeah 20 years time
yeah
that's for sure time shoes better be
like the official shoe of like south
africa they gotta everyone should have a
pair of time shoes
um so her name is uh paige how do you
say their last name mikowski uh blake
and so anyway um so her this woman paige
and her brother is blake the guy started
tom's they got kind of popular and they
got seed money because they were on like
this thing called uh you probably knew
all about this the amazing raise
um and so they like did that and got a
little bit of seed money whatever
so he starts toms the same day she
starts a different company called
aviator nation now you are not in the
target demographic of aviator nation
it's mostly women particularly like
young like high school and i think
middle school girls like it's like a
status symbol a little bit but basically
she uh uh taught herself how to sew just
like on youtube and she started going to
like fairs like venice beach uh flea
markets and things like that and she
would sew like these interesting stripes
on like old vintage sweatshirts like you
know nothing like breathtaking but kind
of cool and like she would be making
like five or 10k a day every once in a
while when she would go and it was kind
of working and she bootstrapped this
business to the point of 16 years later
um she owns 100 of the company in 2020
it did 70 million in revenue 2021 110
million in revenue 2022 it's going to
double again so it's going to be north
of 200 in revenue and last year she paid
herself a 50 million dollar dividend
check and she's buying a lot of
she's yeah she's buying a lot of real
estate with it and in this uh article i
read forbes was like we estimated that
she's worth around 350 million dollars
but she said the number is at least
double that and she recently acquired
her ninth property a 15 million dollar
lakeside house in austin and she has
other homes in malibu venice beach
marina del rey and ask in a aspen ski
chalet and uh
she says that if if she didn't subscribe
to my first million none of this would
have happened that is [__] crazy
dude
yeah she said she reads the milk road
every day yeah
she subscribes and shares with friends
like unbelievable
yeah what a sweetheart and uh
have you have you ever heard of this
business i've never heard about this
until forbes did an article on it
no and this i'm i don't know why but i'm
almost mad
i don't even know what i'm mad at but
i'm just like this because you go to the
website
you go to the website and this literally
could be
like someone's school project this could
be like an aliexpress demo site this
could be and i don't i don't mean that
to to kind of [__] on it but i'm like
what am i looking at this is basically
like
a shirt with four stripes on it it's
like uh you know like a sweater with a
lightning bolt it's like a dude wearing
black shorts with a yellow stripe on the
side
and
the short oh wow the shorts are 168
dollars yeah so and i forgot to add that
that's like the shtick which is it's uh
like sweatpants are 160 so like the
items of clothing are luxury brand yeah
a little bit short of luxury but like
basically my friend joe told me that his
uh kids wear it or they always like are
wanting it because
they'll see girls in school wearing it
and it's like 150 dollars for a pair of
sweatpants and so this is a mystery box
for me like how do you do this how do
you make something just like arbitrarily
cool and in demand when it seems like
there are a trillion you know like
alternatives to this and like i kind of
get it when it's like established brands
it's like oh yeah well you know louis
vuitton or whatever they have this like
history of like being seen as valuable
so therefore people will continue saying
it valuable this is just like
some woman at her dining table was like
no you know what
three stripes on the hoodie
eight hundred dollars
this plan will work and like somehow it
did i don't under
explain this so like makes my head hurt
listen in that book what's peter thiel's
book zero to one he talks about like
he's like there's like basically like
these i don't remember the words he used
but he said like there's like a moat or
like the truth uh like you have to know
something that no one else knows and
basically you have to like figure out
some a secret some type of like
technology that others haven't figured
out but he goes and peter thiel is like
this kind of like autistic-y like genius
and he's like the fifth one is branding
which i don't know anything about that i
don't know about cool but i know that
that's like important that's kind of
like what he says in the book he's like
branding is like a moat but like you
know i don't know anything about moats i
i just do technology and i think that
i've been chatting with a remember how
we had sophia omarosa on the on the on
the pod she's the woman who started
nasty gal she's got all these other new
projects going on and like a woman like
her just everything she does to me is
just like cool it just looks well when i
met when we when we met her i was like
oh yeah like whatever you are selling
i'm buying like
uh dig your vibe you seem awesome like
you're wearing like six rings right now
i don't even own one i feel like i
should own six now like i don't know
what's happening but like i am drawn
to your lifestyle your charisma or
whatever and i think that's like the
you know whatever like you know that
works for nasty gal i think it works for
like goop and [__] like that where it's
like there's just something about
certain taste makers and trendsetters
where you're like exactly all right i
just want to like i just want to drink
whatever you're drinking well if you
google this woman paige um she kind of
has that vibe she's like the jessica
simpson version of nasty gal like maybe
a little bit
like maybe like a little bit less like
edgy but like still cool
uh right you know like uh like just a
little bit more like uh she always looks
like she just got back from coachella
yeah oh you just got back
yeah like she's not gonna do coke with
you but like she'll have like really
good peach iced tea but it's still like
cool and like you always like you're
like oh what the hell what the [__] is
this hibiscus stuff like that type of
the vibe and uh anyway i like her i love
this woman paige i have been reading all
about her this company is really really
cool and you're in the you're in the
ecomm space a bunch of our friends are
in the ecom space and it's really hard
right now and i've read about this woman
and i was like oh well she sure makes it
look kind of easy it's kind of
interesting exactly i think that's why i
have such a big reaction to it because
i'm an ecommerce i'm just like how how
the oh how do you do this you know you
ramped up to 200 million in sales with
like the most
competitive common category like shirts
oh no yeah okay what makes your shirts
good
they're just cool you know i'm like yeah
yeah but that doesn't count for 100
million and it's like actually it can if
you really are cool enough and you build
that grassroots thing what i want to
learn and i don't know if there's a way
to even like figure out this backstory
without doing a bunch of work but like
the there is something to like the
foundation of cool right so like um how
do you build
a frame a foundation or like a ladder
that will
that will like you know started it
sounds like she went to festivals and
she's in the for the first store was in
haiti ashbury and in san francisco and
it's like with the right group of people
you start getting going and then it kind
of like spreads from there and i've
never understood that when it comes to
fashion i never understood but her
brother has that too so if you google
blake myoski and you see like his house
like he's got like a vintage
uh like a vintage like toyota land
cruiser truck with like a golden
retriever and like a cool like
pennington pendleton whatever it's
called blanket like laying over the hood
and like skis on top of the truck in
front of their malibu like even though
it's like you know they're just wealthy
so it's maybe it's easy like have all
that cool [__] there is like a sense of
style uh that he's just always had i i
think part of the cool thing is you just
you're just good looking to be honest i
think that's definitely like
get to the root of it
right i mean like brad pitt could wear
anything and then i could wear the same
clothing it's just like he just looks
better he's just better looking i mean
of course like he's cooler but there is
a few other things i think that that are
a little bit more uh learnable and and
replicable when it comes to that but
these people definitely have it
it reminds me uh so yesterday i was
talking to my mom and my mom's in town
or my mom was like visiting my house and
uh i started doing this thing i did a
podcast with my mom where i was like i
really want to hear my mom's story like
uh because we all talk to our moms but
we don't like really talk it's like
surface level stuff or it's all about
the kid and you know moms are great
because they're like you know they're
all about you but like how often do you
really
sit down and ask them questions about
like them and they're how they grew up
and what made them them so i recorded
this podcast with my mom because you
know parents are getting older and i
just always wanted to have it it was
amazing and one of the things she had
told me i don't know if i shared the
story on the podcast before but she had
told me like
her trip to america
like how she got here
and like um
and it wasn't hardship like um
it wasn't hardship like oh my god we we
were smuggled in and boats and like we
had to like you know walk through the
rio grande with just our nose above the
water like it wasn't hard like that it
was hard in the way that's like very
relatable in that just unknown you just
don't know what you don't know and then
you're in a situation and there's nobody
to help you and so she talked about like
she got on the plane and like uh she saw
the seat belt they're like fashion
seatbelt ma'am and she's like you know
like a plane seat belt is not like any
other seat belt you've ever seen and i
don't know how
she was like and she's just like
clacking it together over and over again
and she just like goes in
and like she was so happy like oh my god
like thing number one done like i could
do this and then she was like all right
i'm flying to america like i don't want
to miss my stop because she'd only ever
been on a train so she's like wide awake
for like 16 hours of a flight being like
when are they gonna announce like the
america stop and i need to get off this
this plane and like she didn't know that
a plane just like goes to one place and
that's it and there was like so many
things like when she got to the place
that she got to jfk or something like
that she needed to transfer
to pittsburgh she just didn't know she
was like i think i'm in america like i
didn't really know beyond that like i
have to get to pittsburgh what is a
pittsburgh and she's like um
she was like 20 at the time and she put
like her 20 is like today's like
seven-year-old like because
she had never been to a restaurant she
couldn't speak english she um like she
told me once she's like
yeah right before i went to america she
told me that yesterday she goes i went
as like our school thing we went to a
restaurant and i'd never eaten outside
of my house
and so i was like oh okay and she's like
there was like a fork and knife on the
table and i didn't know like i knew what
they were but i didn't know how you hold
them and she's like i'm looking around
and everybody's doing it so fast and i'm
like okay what what are they doing with
their like how do they pick this up like
this and she's like i basically didn't
eat i paid for the most expensive meal
of my life and i didn't know how to get
the food into my mouth i was so
embarrassed to use my hands i just
didn't do it and so i was hearing these
stories and i was like
we all have these moments where like the
world seems too
mysterious for us like this is like i
don't know what this this black box is
like completely foreign to me and i
don't know how to operate it and like
her trip to america had like five of
these like she was talking about like
when she finally got off the plane and
the uh american guy had met her and it
was like
okay you clearly look like completely
panicked he was like do you know like
where you're going like do you have a
family to come pick you up and she's
like
no like
why did you have somebody's phone number
would she go to college or something
uh she was even younger she was actually
she was 17 she was she started high
school three days later in america when
she came and so she she came because if
you come right before your 18th birthday
you're not an adult yet so you have to
do way less paperwork so her dad like
put her on a plane at 17 was like go
you're like you're about to turn 18 in
three days like you need to get over
there
and so her brother was here but uh you
know like she didn't know how to get to
his house she didn't know like all the
steps it takes to get there so this guy
was like do you have her phone number
his phone number and she was like yeah
yeah look i have a phone number and he's
like okay let's go to this pay phone
and he's like and she was like i don't
know what this is like i don't know what
this device is and i don't have money
and i don't know how to do this so he
pay he puts quarters in and he calls and
then she's like she talks to her brother
and brother's like whoa you're here like
i didn't even know you're coming like
okay
stay exactly where you are don't move i
will go to the airport and i'll find you
at the at the phone booth do not move
like one step and she's like okay
and she's like the guy who had helped me
like set up the phone call he had to go
catch his next flight or he was she
speak english
she could like read english but she
couldn't speak it she'd never practice
speaking so she like you know was here
and she's like oh [__] and so she was
like she was like i'll never forget
she's like i was
trying to like i was done with the phone
call but i didn't understand how to hang
up the phone i couldn't like i couldn't
figure out how to get the pay phone back
like what was the original starting
point i didn't remember and she's like i
remember i just like left it hanging
like the cord hanging the phone was
swinging i like walked away and i was so
scared like the police are gonna get me
for what i just did and she's like
everything was so new like you know on
the way home we stopped at a 7-11 and i
was like
this is a palace like
look at how much stuff is here look how
bright these lights are i've never seen
lights so bright in my life and like you
know all every little thing was so
amazing and so i say this for two
reasons one is if you haven't done like
the kind of like podcast with your mom
go do it it's amazing even if you don't
have a podcast you don't need to publish
it well just like few people are gonna
have as good of a story as that
i don't know like i feel like
everybody's got a story when you start
to dig in and then for my mom it was
almost like she didn't think about this
stuff like it was only like halfway
through when i got to like the
interesting bit because it was all like
just so buried in her head you know she
what does she remember from 40 years ago
but then she did remember once i got
like on the right trail uh but the other
thing is like when i hear the story
about this woman who you know
just put stripes on a t-shirt and like
grows it like crazy and i'm saying that
kind of like to me it looks so simple
but obviously there's more to it i just
don't know what the more to it is and
i'm sure there's people who listen to
this podcast and they hear these things
i hear us talk about many things and
they're like
i feel like you guys say it like it's so
obvious but it's like completely not
obvious to me it's like where do how do
i hang up the pay phone like how do i
connect the the seat belt um like i
don't know that's okay like there is
that everybody's got that black box and
then like later you look back and you
laugh and you're like yeah so can't
believe it
you you and i you're i i don't you're
not an immigrant but but
you and most all of my friends and i
think you as well all of our friends are
either immigrants or kids of immigrants
um i i feel like i'm like the only like
not
not one of those that that i'm i'm close
with my my wife is that my family's that
you're that and um
what you what you notice talking to
these people and a lot of you and i are
friends with a lot of immigrant
entrepreneurs or children of immigrants
and their entrepreneurs and you you like
i often wonder i'm like how are these
people succeeding when there's
it's they're coming from a place where
things are much harder you know like i i
i didn't learn how to i didn't have to
learn how to you know use a pay phone i
just knew and you hear the story about
your mom and you're like well that's why
they succeed so well because
well she had to learn how to use a fork
like that's like
i imagine like pretty humiliating and
you're frightened you're frightened you
get on a plane to like you know it
sounds like to her it'd be as as if you
sent me to uh the moon you know what i
mean you're like what the hell like i
don't know i don't know anything and
it's like well okay i like landed it i
found my brother somehow like what's the
worst that can happen they're going to
send me back to this play i mean like
you know
it can't be that bad uh failing failing
at least and so when you talk about
people who are like well i don't know
what to do it's like
yeah but like it's kind of
straightforward you just can't really be
afraid to do it because like the worst
that's going to happen is not that bad
like you know what i mean if this woman
from india can come knowing nothing and
she ends with like this big family and
she's
your parents are pretty successful like
it can work out if you just kind of take
a little bit of risk
it's pretty inspiring
our software is the worst have you heard
of hubspot see most crms are a cobble
together mess but hubspot is easy to
adopt and actually looks gorgeous i
think i love our new crm our software is
the best hubspot grow better
yeah i think that's where two common
immigrant traits come from number one
like a willingness to grind it out in a
way that's like
nothing is beneath me you know like okay
like she was like you know two weeks
later i had a job as a waitress
like the person who had never been to a
restaurant now was hired as a waitress
in america and couldn't speak english
and she's like my brother was like how
the hell did you get a job and she's
like i don't know you said we needed a
job and so i just kept going to
different places every like hour i just
went to a different place to interview
and
this one liked me and they just gave me
the job and like okay i have to go at
like four in the morning before school
and like i'm gonna you know help clean
the stuff and then i'm gonna go at night
and like that's what i'll do and so that
you get this like grit side but then you
also get the like
kind of like why are immigrants so cheap
it's because like they've operated with
no safety net before and so now when
they have some resources they're like
don't squander them we remember what it
was like to have no resources with no
back no net to catch you if you fall
and so like yeah don't like spend too
much even once like a lot of immigrant
parents end up in america like they end
up getting rich but they still live very
cheaply and i think it's because like
if you've lived it's like you know
somebody who's like i don't know they
like grew up in the woods and it's like
oh why do you sleep on the floor still
it's like i just do okay like don't ask
me too many questions it's like i know i
have a bed now but like i don't need i
don't need the bed i don't i don't want
to use that right now because i feel
like you know anything could happen
right now and so well a lot of my same
fear and a lot of my friends so my
mother-in-law's from haiti and i would
talk to her so she did i tell you how
she started this pillow business i don't
know how big it is exactly but i imagine
mid six figures and um she took she
asked me to to take drive me two hours
to the airport and i was like why she's
like i want to ask you how shopify works
i think i want to create an online store
where i sell these pillows and i'm like
all right whatever i'll explain to you
how to do it but i like people ask me
this all the time they never follow up
and they never do anything and so she
calls me six weeks later she's like
alright i got my first sale now what
it's like oh my god and i was talking to
her and the way that they would describe
it you know my
in-law my in-laws as well as my other
other immigrant friends it's kind of
like what's interesting is when you take
like these immigrants and you put them
in america where there's like a pretty
strict rules and
laws like and like mostly the government
can't take things from you and like your
stuff is mostly protected it's like well
this is easy this is not easy mode like
like we all know we all know the rules
and we know that people are mostly all
gonna follow the rules like this is easy
this is just a board game like you just
gotta play it
and uh and so i'm always inspired
hanging out with those types of people
yeah for sure me too uh you said
something just now which is like
i think is an important
uh little
thing which was i tell people the stuff
all the time and like very few take
action like most people just don't do
anything with this i've been kind of
i've been admiring there's been a bunch
of people who have built cool [__] for
us
that like
i just want to call out is kind of
awesome and i don't know where it leads
and i like that they did it knowing not
where it leads but something good is
going to happen i'll give you give you a
couple examples
somebody created this thing i don't know
if you saw it they put it on product
hunt it's like the mfm ideas system i i
wish i knew the link off top of my head
but if you go to production you search
my first million um
basically he went and indexed
like i don't know
30 or 40 percent of all of the different
ideas we've said on this podcast where
we're like oh mailchimp but for inside
your company because
you need to write internal newsletters
blah blah blah and so they'll take that
idea he time stamped it and so you can
go to the website and it will be you'll
just be like give me an idea and it'll
give you an idea and then it says listen
to it and you click it and it opens up
in spotify or whatever some player like
exactly where we talked about that idea
and i was like wow this is so awesome
for us but also for anybody who's a fan
of the podcast
um
and immediately i was like drawn to this
person and and it's such a it's such a
hack to stand out
just by like doing a useful thing
and there's so much energy that gets
spent like
reading books listening to podcasts like
ask asking people for advice
you know and it's like dude you know
instead spend actually like a one-third
of the time and actually like
build something or make something that's
like kind of interesting
uh that will get you so much further
there's another guy who built this thing
called writelikeshawn.com have you seen
this that was really good it was great
this guy created this thing he trained
gpt3 like like the
ai model or whatever
to on a bunch of my twitter threads and
he goes oh yeah i trained this ai to
write like you so watch you can just
type in any topic and it'll spit out a
twitter thread
and i was like okay yeah i did it it was
awesome it was great it's actually
awesome
this guy someone put it in there um let
me let me find it he put in
i'm gonna pull this up pretty amazing
how the uh the the language like it is
it is like you i i put something in
there and like the cadence sounded
exactly like you
so uh okay so
this person
uh where's the one
somebody wrote how to pick up girls or
whatever
or somebody wrote how to be happy
and then it goes you don't find
happiness you create it most people go
through life searching for happiness
they think that when they find the right
job right relationship right house
they'll finally be happy but the truth
is happiness comes from within here's
how you create it yourself number one do
something that makes you happy every day
it doesn't have to be big it can be
small like this is a [__] computer
that's writing a very realistic
you know looking thing uh here's another
one um why we don't do public math right
somebody's a fan of the podcast he goes
we don't do public math think about it
when's the last time you did math in
public i mean really did math addition
subtraction multiplication not mental
math but using your fingers a calculator
or a piece of paper
when's the last time you saw someone do
math in public it's almost like we're
ashamed of it we don't want people to
see a struggle at math we think they'll
think we're stupid but the truth is math
is hard and it's normal to struggle with
it so let's start doing public math like
it like changes our whole perspective by
the end let's try practice public math
period together how does how did how did
how can i make one of those because i
would like to do that for my stuff and
just still write emails for me
so what do you do you just like tell
gpthree to read all of your tweets and
it gets to you yeah we should just get
this guy so this guy
uh
adil pickle is his name is his like
twitter handle i told him because i i
put it in my newsletter i was like check
this out this is awesome and it like
crashed his site and he ran up a
thousand dollar bill before it crashed
the site he's like ah i know my side
project i was like dude i'll like i'll
pay your bill just let me own the thing
and i'll pay your bill like it's my it's
right like sean i'll buy it off you and
then you don't have to worry about this
stuff um and so because i i think it'd
be cool to like like i love uh john
steinbeck um i've been reading it you
know you you don't even know who that is
dude
famous american author whatever a
classic american author like you know
like the he's like from the crew that
wrote like uh catcher in the ride that
type of crap i would love to like write
my marketing emails
like those guys
and i think it'd be cool if i could if i
could figure out how to like teach gpd3
what um
you want to go to a different cry into
the background i don't know if you could
hear it
that's all right what topics you want to
go to
um well there is a couple others on this
like gpt3 thing yeah like um
so basically like this the ai has gotten
really really good at really specific
things like i don't know have you played
with dolly that's that yeah that is the
craziest [__] on earth
that is way crazier than gbt three
it's the picture version of this you
just type in
any concept it's like
um sampar
surfing while smoking a cigarette and
it'll generate like
12 pictures like
ai illustrates sampar on a surfboard
smoking a cigarette it'll give you a
bunch of variations dude i told it to do
wild [__] i said do real-life grown-up
cartman and bart simpson
and it made a real life like a it looked
like a photo a photograph of what a
grown-up cartman from south park a
cartoon looked like it was crazy
it is so impressive this is like the
demo version it's not even the real
version i'm going to start doing a thing
um there's this company i want to invest
in that does this with voices and so
uh basically he sent me a clip of
um
of gary vee reading the milk road
so it was like you know
it goes good morning you know
is like the garyvee voice it read the
thing and it sounds exactly like garyvee
and then he's like here's jordan
peterson doing it here's joe rogan doing
it here's garyvee doing it and he's like
if you give me like 16 hours of like
your podcast audio data like i'll just i
can make your voice like a synthetic
voice so then you could like you could
just type something and um it'll do
it'll record the audio for you the way
you talk
and i was like what in the world is
going on so this stuff is so amazing to
me it's really captured by fascination
and it's just the beginning like this is
gonna get so much better and has all
kinds of crazy implications like
hey you're not gonna know what's real
and what's fake like cause fake and real
are gonna be like indistinguishable like
like a deep fake video or like a
photoshopped photo but for everything
for voices for videos for drawings for
whatever uh twitter threads like it's
not unreasonable that like most of the
content you read on the internet is just
gonna be written by computers
dude like you're gonna go on twitter
it's just gonna be auto-generated
content from brands and and and people
that are you know just plugging it into
the ai and ai's spitting out good
content for us all to consume like we
may not have hollywood at some point
it'll just be like computers making
movies and the rest of us just like you
know wally what's that movie where
they're like fat people sitting in
wheelchairs and just like sucking down
slurpees and watching stuff it'll just
be that because it's like oh we don't
need to do the work to make stuff
anymore so the computers make awesome
movies we just watch them
dude let me let me tell you a quick
story
as we kind of wrap up real quick about
you know how like you know it's not for
a little while it's been not cool to
live in a city lately and it's been cool
to live in like uh less popular places
like in portland austin that type of
thing
last night i went to a wedding i went it
was my wife's buddy's wedding
so they weren't like you know my friend
they weren't like what i thought were
like you know our startup eating early
friends and i sat at this table
and listened to my table i didn't know
who any people were they were we just
started chit chatting the the person
next to me started a business that had
raised uh 30 million dollars
at a star and these all these people are
about 28 years old
had raised like 30 million dollars the
person next to them had a company that
in two years hired 300 people the person
next to them had a startup that they
sold for 140 million dollars the person
next to them had a vc fund that had a
billion dollars raised and they this
person graduated college in
09 so however old you are 33 with that
and then the person next to them was um
a partner at one of the biggest
management consulting firms and so it's
like mostly like and then there's some
poor like english teacher in the middle
who's just like what am i what is this
come on come on do it here
why
i'm the one doing real work out here so
no one was douchey at all so the reason
why i even knew that was because they
like had seen sarah post about me and
they're like oh you do the podcast about
startups i was like oh yeah okay so you
must be in startups too yeah i work at
this company oh what do you do there oh
i actually started it so like they're
trying to they're being cool about it so
um
it it
it was pretty inspiring to be around
these people i'm used to like you know
sometimes being like
a big shot sometimes amongst my my like
non-entrepreneurial friend group and i
go around these people and i'm like oh
my god like this is like incredibly
motivating i actually think that there's
a world where it's a little unhealthy
because uh
you're like you know like this money
[__] doesn't actually matter that much
but it's so it's kind of [__] that
i'm like comparing myself to others but
it's incredibly incredibly motivating
and that's something that i miss about
san francisco uh and we had that for a
little while
yeah that is that was the best part
about san francisco by far like people
like how san francisco it's like oh well
the city is basically gotham city uh you
know it's cold it's not actually like
warm california weather
uh you know it's super expensive it's
you know all these things
um
but
the upside is like you know
if you want to hang out with some of the
most ambitious interesting people who
like look at the world a little
differently and are kind of crazy enough
to go pursue it
you're just going to keep bumping into
them like everywhere you go regardless
what you're doing and sure enough your
brain will start to change to be more
like them dude what's funny is i feel
like our friends weren't even ambitious
like
you know like jack smith is not an
ambitious person he just like works on
interesting things and just so happens
that they become huge money making
operations or like we have a few friends
that are ambitious but we have a bunch
of friends it's just like
i don't think jack i think is more of an
outlier jackie is more like just like
curious and mischievous more than he is
ambitious
but i don't think most people are like
jack i think jack's a bit of an outlier
i don't consider myself to be ambitious
do you consider yourself to be ambitious
you you are ambitious yes you are i
don't consider a lot of our friends i'm
just like we just like doing interesting
things and it just so happens that the
output is yeah but yours is like jax is
like i like doing interesting things as
in like he'll build a ergonomic chair in
his garage to like see what that's like
your version is like i like just doing
interesting things that are highly
profitable and like
there's a caveat there's like an
important caveat to your like you're not
like just reading novels from like you
know uh 18th century you're like
okay how do i you know spin up this
thing that's gonna get to six figures in
revenue very quickly right like that's
that's your version of what's
interesting what's interesting to you is
kind of the the hook right so like
what's interesting to people like okay
ferkan i would say is very ambitious
he's not very money-minded
right ambition is not money it's like
but he's like super interested in new
tech and so
you know our office would have like oh
he you know here's why why doesn't the
tv remote work oh sorry i changed the t
i like took the chip out of the tv i put
a raspberry pi in it's like why can't i
use this beer tap oh because i put a
[__] like drone that floats above it
and like you know
like what is this where's my computer
it's like oh i needed a place to put my
3d printer and like eight out of ten of
those turned out to be just like you
know money sucks like there's there was
no commercial value in the raspberry pi
or the mini drones or the 3d printing or
any of that stuff it was just like the
fifth one where he's like yeah i'm
playing around with this like crypto
thing you know this thing how ethereum
just came out and it's like just
happened to be that that one was like
one that turned out to be extremely
profitable and like you know changed the
world in a bigger way but you know the
interest was in let's say for him tech
or like our buddy xavier is just like
dude how do i provide electricity to
people in africa who don't have it right
that's ambition in a different way right
and
that was inspiring right like i was like
holy [__] you're the biggest solar
provider in africa but i guess what i
mean is like in in new york i noticed
that the ambition is like uh let me
crawl up this ladder and climb to the
top of the ladder because i want to be
number one and i'm gonna kick other
people off the ladder and make sure like
stomp on their face as i'm going up so
they can't get as high as as i am right
whereas it seems that maybe i'm just
being like uh just
i just think our [__] don't stink which
is it's more like let's create new
ladders
you know
it's like here's the test of new york
it's like do you know which finger can
take the least amount of pressure before
it gives up its grip it's like yeah step
on the ring finger they're done
it's like
whereas in san francisco it's a little
bit different right san francisco the
virtue signaling is different like what
you get rewarded for
is different you get rewarded for
uh i'm solving some big problem at scale
billion users billion dollar prize
that's what you're going for and it's
okay like your high status if you're
broke but going for a big
big prize whereas in new york you don't
get high status for broke like it's like
san francisco it's like
the guy with the biggest ratio of
wealth
to poor looking is like the winner you
know like you you have to be like the
most raggedy looking dude with the most
amount of money yeah yeah make the most
money and then give up all your
possessions and live on the street like
that is the like peak right that's like
jack go look at jack dorsey it's like
okay you build
two multi-billion dollar companies but
then you grow a homeless man beard and
you like pretend you don't care about it
you give all your money away and you
wear a tie-dye t-shirt and like you know
you carry around a notebook and like
that's you know while you walk barefoot
it's like that that's the highest status
like person you can be in silicon valley
what did you think of the peter lovells
podcast
i thought it was dope like i think he's
great uh i like him like
you know um
i always liked his content but i like
him i didn't know him um and i like the
way he thinks i like the way he acts i
thought he was i thought he was pretty
honest
like he didn't come on here and try to
perform
um
and he got the vibe he got the the you
know i think he's a hit he's a hit i
like him
there's a handful of people who we were
friends with and who we've talked to
publicly who i think i would put in the
category of like oh they've kind of
figured it out and of course that
they're flawed and they make mistakes
and they're not always happy and
whatever that just like normal humans
but like in general they've kind of got
it figured out i would say darmesh is in
that category where it's like oh man
you've like you have a lot of the boxes
checked up like you seem happy you seem
like you got a good family your career
is good jack smith our good buddy is
another one of those people uh he
started a company that he sold for 800
million dollars but like he's not that
like he doesn't really care about that
and he'll never tell you about it unless
you ask about it but he's happy and
healthy and then this guy levels peter
levels i would put him in the same
category where it's like you kind of
like seem like you know what you want
and you stick with it and you have
principles and you're
you're achieving exactly your ideal life
right and that's by the way
you know the you know the tell that i
figured out like the what's the quickest
way for me to pick up on is that person
like those people like our some of our
favorite people are like that i put suli
in that category i put ferkan in that
category i put a bunch of ramones in
that category
it's what percent of your like kind of
when you talk about
yourself or what you're doing
what percent
there's two tests one is what percent of
a conversation do you talk about
yourself
versus your asked questions you're
interested or curious about other things
other people other things then the
second is when you talk about yourself
what percent is talking about the past
stuff you've done versus stuff you're
interested in doing or the future and it
sounds very simple but i'll like if you
go to their bios very few of them even
have their last company in their bio
whereas if you go to my bio it's like
sold bebo right like number one the
first thing i write in there is like
sold the thing you know like i've done
something cool please ask me about it i
love to tell you about my wins and
you're fairly you're you're fairly close
to being in that category of like i feel
like you know what you want and even if
you don't get what you want you're still
mostly happy
yeah and the the thing that's helped me
is like
uh i'm getting away from doing that i'm
getting away from basically trying to
like
seek validation in some way and then the
second like that that's that's why we
talk about our past right to like
kind of like give ourselves some status
or to get some validation from others is
like you know here's my background
here's what i've done
therefore please give me some respect
and and whatever else and once i picked
up that these other guys do that very
differently i started to
shed that it's like somebody will bring
something up in a conversation i i think
of an anecdote where i can tell them a
really cool story of how i've done that
and i'm just like well that doesn't
actually add to the conversation they're
already convinced why do i need to do
that i don't need to i don't need to
perform here it's fine and so i like let
that go and that thought never used to
be let go it always used to be something
i would
immediately jump in at any opportunity
to kind of like
you know hey can you validate my parking
here here's my ticket stub can you
please punch a hole in it and like
that's how i felt like i was doing stuff
and then i noticed these guys don't do
that and i talked i remember asking
silly i go i feel like you never
i kind of have to brag for you when we
meet people because like
dude they don't even know who you are
they don't know you're a hit like how
much of a hitter you are and you want to
look and sean wants to look cooler that
he's associated with julian why did i
bring this guy to this meeting yeah
because this guy's [__] awesome and
like hold on you didn't do it you didn't
brag let me brag yeah
and um and i was like i was like why do
you do that i was like as i also feel
like you don't even talk about or think
about like all the stuff you've done in
the past and like
he was like he's like yeah i mean i
don't i don't know i don't really do i
don't really feel the need to he's like
you know i heard kobe bryant give a talk
once and he's like it was after kobe
retired
and he was talking about like the new
[__] he was into he's like cause i don't
know if you know kobe started like
making little mini movies and like he
like got really into storytelling and
movies and like that was like what he
wanted to do right great stories movies
and stuff yeah and so he was like
creating he created like a production
company
and kobe had said something that was
like i need my next 20 years to make my
last 20 years like a footnote like the
next 20 years need to be the best thing
i've ever done and this is coming from
one of the greatest hall of fame
basketball players whereas if you see
what most players do when they retire
they go put on a suit they put on 30
pounds and then they go sit at an espn
desk and they talk about how the players
these days don't get it back in my day
we used to be so great and like they and
they never like move on to the next
great adventure and they don't they
think it's it's implicit that the best
work of their life was behind them and
that's why they gained the weight that's
why they aren't as happy that's why
they're nostalgic for the good old days
whereas somebody who looks at it like oh
this next chapter is my best chapter and
that's a different that person's gonna
like go through life a little
differently and so he told me he's like
when i heard that i thought the same
thing like oh yeah great
my next company it needs to make my last
company be this like little afterthought
like we'll put it in the appendix of
like stuff i'm done
and if i think about it that way then i
won't put so much emphasis on it i won't
use it as my crutch as like a way to get
kind of respect or attention or anything
like that i'm gonna only make my new
thing the way i do it and um and i
really respected that i was like that's
great have you heard the song uh damn it
feels good to be a gangster
of course basically uh in one of the
lines he says real gangsters don't flex
nuts because they know they got him
and
that's that's what we're talking about
here
you don't flex nuts because you know you
got them yeah exactly exactly
i think that's the episode
[Music]
you